we start today with Republicans in
shambles as what they expected and
believed would happen at the U.S Mexico
border when pandemic era title 42
guidelines expired did not happen the
Border was not overrun as biden-like
border patrol lay down it would whatever
hypothetical insane conspiracy theory
Republicans believed was going to
transpire did not transpire but let me
tell you what is going on Bloomberg
reports border crossings
fall 50 percent easing fears of U.S
migration surge surge the number of
migrants seeking to cross the U.S
Southern U.S border has been markedly
down during the past two days bucking
expectations of a surge after pandemic
era border rules expired the U.S border
Patrol quote has experienced a 50 drop
in the number of encounters versus what
we were experiencing earlier in the week
before the restrictions known as title
42 were lifted
it's too soon to say whether the numbers
have peaked border agents reported about
6 300 encounters on Friday 4 200 on
Saturday that's down from a record high
of about 10 000 a day early last week so
there's a couple of different things
that are important to talk about here
first what are we talking about when we
talk about title 42 title 42 was not
created by Trump but it was used by
Trump as an emergency measure in the
context of the pandemic to more quickly
turn around those undocumented
immigrants encountered by immigrations
enforcement agencies like border patrol
instead of a longer process before they
could be deported and sent back to their
country of origin title 42 allowed to
allowed it to be done more quickly now I
don't want to focus on the obvious
absurdity
of the very same Republicans who said
kovid's no big deal
on the other hand on the other side of
their mouth saying covet is such a big
deal that we need to enact an emergency
measure because it's so big a deal we
need to turn around undocumented
immigrants instead of giving them the
due process that they normally get let's
put that aside because that's beyond the
scope of this conversation the
expectation that we've been hearing is
that the Biden border policy is a
disaster it's essentially no border we
don't have a country anymore you know
you've heard this stuff before
uh and thus when title 42 expired it was
just going to be a deluge of who knows
hundreds of thousands millions of
undocumented immigrants rushing over
what actually happened is that the
number of encounters declined now
there's another aspect to this that I
think is important to discuss which is
that of encounters as a sign
that the Border policy is being enforced
or that it isn't one of the things we
heard endlessly from Republicans was we
know tons of people are getting over the
Border because of the number of
individuals that are being stopped and
countered and stopped by border patrol
Marjorie Taylor green would often say
look that we now have a hundred thousand
encounters a week of people that are
being stopped the border is broken and
of course if you were thinking clearly
and rationally you would say wait those
people are being stopped that means it's
not an open border and then they would
come back and say well no the number of
individuals encountered and stopped is a
proxy for the number that get through
this is an argument they made by their
very standard
if now we are seeing the number of
encounters decline dramatically by their
logic the number of folks that are
getting through without being stopped
must also be declining dramatically
again this is not me saying it this is
by their own logic will they acknowledge
that no they won't instead what they're
focusing on is that when Biden was
interviewed riding his bike over the
weekend he said he doesn't currently
have plans to go to the border and in
fact when you listen to the reasoning he
gives it kind of makes a lot of sense
things are going at the border sir
my prayer than you all expected do you
have any plans today I think pardon me
do you have any plans to visit the
Border
not in the near term no no just be
disruptive not anything else yeah
why aren't you going to go to the Border
well it would just be disruptive that's
absolutely true Republicans love to
pretend that the only way to manage the
situation on the border is for Joe Biden
to go and to do a photo op and to
inspect the Border fence and this sort
of thing why do they think that well
because that's what they expect from the
Republican politicians who do those
types of photo ops all the time they
bring a desk they put it so absurd the
visuals they bring a desk and put it at
the border and sit there and say we're
meeting we're meeting with border patrol
oh but really what you're doing is
you're actually creating a lot of
logistical work for security and all
travel all these different things the
allegation initially was when title 42
expires it'll be a disaster
it hasn't happened now they're shifting
to why won't Biden go to the border and
Biden rightly says because it'll just
become a distraction we will continue to
follow the story but as usual one of the
areas in which they lie the most is that
U.S Mexico border this isn't my
absolutely favorite story from the
weekend remember the Whistleblower who
was going to blow the lid off about the
Biden crime family's fraud and all these
things that Joe Biden and Hunter Biden
have done James Comer was talking about
it we saw clips of Chuck Grassley saying
this is a this is explosive we're going
to bring in The Whistleblower it's all
going to happen
The Whistleblower is now missing
The Whistleblower is now missing and I
know what you're saying they probably
just don't want anything to do with this
right they are using ominous language to
say we we've got to figure that out the
Whistleblower has gone missing
hmm that's really really weird Newsweek
has a report Republican admits key quote
informant against Joe Biden now missing
now Eve the term whistleblower was a
stretch to begin with because
whistleblowers suggests they're blowing
the whistle about some kind of crime so
far we've not seen any evidence of that
neither of Republicans who say oh the
evidence is coming we're going to get
the evidence now the term that's being
used is an informant but even that is
being put within quotes because it's not
even really clear that they are that uh
representative James Comer a Kentucky
Republican admitted Sunday that
Republicans quote lost track of a key
witness in an investigation about the
Biden family's involvement in an alleged
bribery scheme this is just amazing
um there what we what we have is a memo
which includes redacted images of
transactions involving bank accounts
purportedly belonging to members of the
crime of the Biden family which they
believe are evidence of crimes nothing's
actually been proven you have to
understand so we go to Maria bartiromo's
program on Fox News yesterday
and
Maria Bartiromo tries to do this big
dramatic wait a second are you telling
me and it's just all so transparently
pathetic take a look at this hold on a
second Congressman did you just say did
you just say on live television and did
you just say that the Whistleblower or
the informant is now missing
well we we're hopeful that we can find
the Informer now remember these
informants are are kind of in the the
Spy business
it's like did you just say Congressman
you know they came to me and they said
sir the Biden crime witness is missing
big strong guys Tears in their eyes I
said how could that be it was because of
Obama who has been treated has treated
me very very unfairly because the
cupboards were bare when I took over for
him I was getting calls day and night
saying sir how do you do it how are you
doing it and we're going to be redoing
Mount Rushmore very strongly because the
informant proves everything about the
Biden crime family oh we can't find him
okay well I'm sure that that's something
that the Biden crime family orchestrated
right it's the hunter Biden body count
or whatever it is the next thing is
going to be
the way that this conversation has gone
if you look at it from the beginning
is so pathetic that it's actually
shocking Maria Bartiromo is even playing
along like even for her is it's it's a
bit much because the way the
conversation has been was Comer and
Grassley and others came forward and
said we have a whistleblower
who has all sorts of incredible evidence
against Joe Biden that crimes were
committed oh okay have you seen the
evidence well no no no but I'm sure that
he has it and we're going to bring him
in very soon oh okay when is he coming
in well actually he's gone missing now
oh that's that's really kind of strange
and Maria Bartiromo falls for the entire
thing here she is wrapping it up on Fox
news and it really seems as though she
will believe anything Republicans tell
her just stunning a stunning breaking
news story this morning that some of
these people now may be missing uh Mr
chairman we're certainly going to be
covering and Reporting your findings
thank you which findings the findings
that there is no more whistleblower
because the Whistleblower is missing or
the findings that you are going to get
only if and when you find The
Whistleblower if you get them to come in
if they have any evidence if any of the
evidence checks out and if any of the
evidence that checks out actually points
to any crime even a single crime which
they've been looking into for years and
still haven't found a shred of evidence
about they love to say you know the left
always goes after Trump for all of this
supposed stuff but now we've got
evidence and they don't want to talk
about it first of all I've covered the
story from the beginning secondly there
isn't actually any evidence claiming
that someone you can't find has evidence
right that is not the same as having
evidence and the entire thing reminds me
of when
Tucker remember Tucker Carlson he went
on TV when he still had a show on Fox
News and he said we got a copy of the
hard drive we got a copy of the laptop
from Hell the hunter Biden laptop from
hell we got the copy on a USB drive
and we sent it to ourselves across the
country and it got lost in the mail
really you didn't make like a cloud
backup you didn't keep a USB drive with
you you didn't think to duplicate it you
know it just it's been lost we we
finally got Hunter's hard drive but it
simply was lost in the mail it's getting
harder to believe that these are serious
people and of course James Comer hasn't
been a serious person for a very long
time so listen as I've said before
I don't care about Hunter Biden in terms
of protecting him or politically
motivated reasons to pretend he did
nothing wrong just find me evidence of
crimes and then I will say prosecute
under Biden but more importantly find me
a link to Joe Biden before I'm going to
think that there's actually political
relevance they have nothing do not allow
yourself to be misled they have nothing
as of right now okay real quick two
weeks from today Monday Memorial Day
we're doing a one-day membership blowout
special to officially start the 2024
campaign the debates are going to start
it's going to be insane okay so Monday
Memorial Day that's the uh 29th I
believe is that right I don't even know
what I don't even know what year it is
yes Monday May 29th one day membership
special biggest discount of the year if
you've been thinking of supporting the
work that we do I would love forget for
you to get on my newsletter mailing list
you go to davidpackman.com you just type
in your email address very easy to do
and a Monday Memorial Day in the morning
you'll get an email and it'll be an
email crying that will tell you how to
take advantage of this great membership
discount I'll say more about it between
now and then
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
well a blockbuster new house Republican
report has investigated President Joe
Biden
and it has found absolutely no
wrongdoing by President Joe Biden it's
really important whenever you hear they
won't even let us investigate big Pharma
won't let us investigate whether niacin
works for depression oh actually there's
a bunch of studies on that that's been
investigated oh well they won't let us
investigate what the vaccine oh the
vaccine's been investigated and they
won't let us test whether
hydroxychloroquine when snorted through
a Neti Pot treats Cove it's they've
looked at hydroxychloroquine so many
times at this point so whenever you hear
we're not even allowed well let's look
as you were hearing on Fox News and
elsewhere that they simply can't get
what they need the Whistleblower is
missing it's all being obstructed they
don't know what crimes Hunter Biden or
Joe Biden might have might have
committed you go to the New York Times
which by the way isn't failing and it's
certainly not fake and you find house
wait a second what house Republican
report
finds no evidence of wrongdoing by
President Biden after months of
Investigation months they've been
they've been looking into this yes after
months of investigation and many public
accusations of corruption against Mr
Biden and his family the first report of
the Premier house Republican this is a
republican inquiry showed no proof of
such misconduct
what and here you see Republicans on the
oversight committee standing very
strongly and announcing we didn't find
any wrongdoing they investigated four
months we'll link to this article by
Luke Broadwater it's a good summary four
months of Investigation House
Republicans promised to use their
majority to unearth evidence of
wrongdoing by Biden acknowledged that
they had yet to uncover
any incriminating material about him
despite frequent insinuations that he
and his family have been involved in
criminal conduct and Corruption
even the Republicans can't find it Well
it must be a cover-up right I mean these
soros-backed Republicans must have been
up to no good or something along those
lines at a much publicized news
conference on Capitol Hill can you
imagine the build up we're finally going
to hear about it they're holding a press
conference they're going to come with
the with the the the receipts and we're
going to find out once and for all all
of the crimes that Biden committed and
they go yeah we actually have no our
preliminary findings are no wrongdoing
whatsoever we found no incriminating
evidence at all
they released financial documents
detailing how some of the presidents
um uh relatives were paid money
during a period of time they are calling
it influence peddling but there's not
actually any evidence of that
uh and they've conceded that there is no
evidence of a specific corrupt action
that Biden has taken while in office not
a single corrupt action in connection
with any of the business deals that
Hunter Biden was involved in they said
uh I mean I I don't know what else to
say they just they don't have any
evidence it also the article also
explains Federal prosecutors have
examined Hunter Biden's international
business activities as part of a
criminal investigation but the only
charges they're considering are
unrelated to his work abroad they
include tax charges related to failure
to file tax returns for several years
and lying about his drug use on a
federal file a form he filled out to
purchase a handgun hey you know what if
that's what you've got Hunter Biden on
by all means go ahead and prosecute
charge them I don't see anyone on the
left running interference for Hunter
Biden to point out that Hunter Biden has
nothing to do with Joe Biden's
presidency that Joe Biden's presidency
has not exhibited any evidence of crime
or fraud of any sort and by the way if
there were such evidence I would want to
know about it I wouldn't work to cover
it up as someone who voted for Biden
over Trump if we have evidence that a
president engaged in fraud
I don't care whether they're a democrat
or a republican I want to see the
evidence so many Republicans responding
to this report by saying clearly this is
part of the cover-up Soros got to the
oversight committee maybe it was antifa
but what they are doing is wasting more
and more and more time and resources and
taxpayer Money for Nothing it may be
time by the way to to close up Obama
gate as well you still remember when
Trump told us Obama gate was the crime
of the century the political crime of
the century and a reporter said can you
tell us what the crimes were and Trump
looked at him and with a straight face
said you know what they are you know
what they are well maybe it's time to
close the book on Obama gate as well I
don't know where we're going on that but
certainly don't seem to be making any
progress whatsoever
I want to propose to you today
that maybe just maybe Donald Trump was
not the worst president in American
history you know when we think about
Trump and Trump's Legacy
Trump was clearly a worse president than
Barack Obama we know that that's clear
Obama Trump was clearly a worse
president than George W bush he was
worse than Bill Clinton he was worse
than George H.W bush Etc but is it
possible that there has been a worse
president than Donald Trump and I am
going to suggest to you today that that
President may have been James Buchanan
what just just hear it out okay James
Buchanan was president from 1857 to
1861. he was a pro-slavery Democrat of
course remember this was before the
realignment uh the party realignment
being a Democrat then is very different
than being you know Adam Schiff today
we're talking about something very
different and Buchanan essentially led
the country to Civil War so let's
compare and contrast elements between
Trump and Buchanan see where we come out
on race relations we might call it you
know Trump inspired and coalesced
racists of all kinds he was extreme
ordinarily racially divisive he
hesitated to condemn white supremacy and
neo-nazism until he had absolutely no
choice he passed and advocated for
policies that were discriminatory
against immigrants and minorities and he
stoked racial tensions with the rhetoric
Buchanan however
was for slavery he was four slave
holders he endorsed the Dred Scott
Decision which denied rights to African
Americans he pressured Kansas to adopt a
pro-slavery Constitution he supported
the secession of southern states which
quite literally would have ripped the
United States apart and he did nothing
to stop the violence between the pro and
anti-slavery factions now you could say
well David you know being pro-slavery at
the time was different because fine okay
but this is James Buchanan now in terms
of legislatively and relationships to
Congress of course Trump's relationship
to Congress was a disaster clashing with
Congress ignoring defying Congressional
subpoenas and oversight requests uh
vetoing some bills overridden by
bipartisan majorities okay but when you
look at Buchanan Buchanan vetoed many
bills completely uncontroversial bills
about land and grants and internal
improvements tariffs which at the time
were arguably necessary and
uncontroversial
Buchanan tried to actually influence
Congressional elections using
intimidation you could say well Trump
did some of these things too sure but
we're saying is it possible Buchanan was
even worse now when we look at crises
that Afflicted each of these
presidencies Trump had a number of
crises uh the pandemic the associated
recession the
um rash of police brutality incidents
that led to protests in favor of racial
Justice obviously inciting an
Insurrection
comically disastrous relationships with
foreign leaders and kowtowing to
dictators all these different things
disastrous handling for sure you know
downplaying the pandemic contradicting
experts spreading misinformation uh
failing on testing and tracing and PPE
you know all all these things lacking
empathy and compassion all of that but
then you say well look at the crisis
that James Buchanan dealt with James
Buchanan dealt with a situation that
quite literally led to a Civil War which
could have ended the United States as we
know it and he handled it you could say
Buchanan's handling of the lead-up to
the Civil War was worse than Trump on
the pandemic it's a different
environment but you could say that
Buchanan said you know secession's not
illegal
uh said I have no power to stop it if
they're going to secede they're going to
secede he said it's the abolitionist's
fault those who want to end slavery are
provoking the South accusing the
abolitionists of treason refusing to
reinforce and resupply federal forts of
all kinds which subsequently were
attacked by Confederate forces you could
say he left he you could say he left
Union forces uh unprotected which is
unbelievably disgusting and he also did
nothing to stop violence in a bunch of
different a bunch of different states so
could the argument be made that Buchanan
was actually the worst president when
you think about the Legacy yeah Trump
was impeached twice and he incited the
Insurrection and failed on covid all of
those things Buchanan quite literally
left a broken nation and I don't say
that metaphor he left a nation in Civil
War which was trying to break itself
apart so I think that it's really
difficult to compare
1861 to 2021 because there are so many
fundamental structural differences that
the country saw during that period of
time of course but I think you could
make the case if you wanted
that Buchanan was a worse president than
Donald Trump betraying his oath of
office and his country and his people
which Trump did too but maybe Buchanan
did it in an even more egregious way let
me know what you think worst Presidents
in history Trump Buchanan someone else
let me know in a comment let us know in
an email we're going to take a very
quick break and be back after this all
of the stuff we've been talking about
today you can find it on our YouTube
channel on our tick tock on our
Instagram it's almost too easy to find
it quite frankly
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's follow the 2024 campaign Trail
around the weekend and take a look at
what happened Donald Trump was scheduled
to do another one of these unhinged lie
rallies the lie a second it's not even
lie a minute it's the lia second rally
in Des Moines Iowa that rally was
ultimately canceled it was reportedly
canceled for bad weather although there
are some who are saying it was canceled
because there were no people and Trump
realized it would be humiliating so we
opted to cancel it I don't know
officially it was canceled for bad
weather this didn't stop the sycophants
and dilettants from uh showing up and uh
praising the cult leader and really
proving Beyond any doubt whatsoever that
this is a cult I'm going to show you a
few examples of this at the rally that
did not happen
here is a guy who was asked you know
Trump's doing a rally in Iowa Ron
DeSantis is also doing an event in Iowa
even though he's not yet running and
this guy says he felt an obligation to
be at the Trump rally why I'll let him
explain it to you I wasn't important
decision-making process
you want to go first I think all of the
attacks against President Trump that are
just totally unprecedented you know the
legal allegations against him I just
feel obligated knowing how much
president Trump has stood up for me and
has stood up for all of these Americans
I feel obligated to come out here and
show my support for him yeah what now
see this is where like if we had Luke
Beasley on the ground he would follow up
and say oh in what way did Trump stand
up for you well he stood up to China for
me oh really how did he stand up to
China and you very quickly see that it's
completely vapid it's just there's
absolutely no substance whatsoever there
then they go to the the guy next to him
with a basically the same question
DeSantis is in the state of Iowa Trump
was scheduled to be in the state of Iowa
before the rally got canceled why are
you here instead of at the DeSantis
event and listen to what this guy says
it's beyond parody things to say
promises made promise is kept and Trump
is the only president ever that has
traded his wealth for his country and
not his country for his not his country
for his wealth Trump earned
1.6 billion dollars personally during
his presidency think about the level of
Disconnect with these people Trump did
something no one else has ever done he
traded his wealth for the country for
the good of the country
he earned 1.6 billion dollars during the
four years that he was supposedly
working for this guy's interests as
president of the United States then they
speak to we're still dealing with the
same group of folks they speak to one of
the women I guess and say if you had the
chance to speak to Donald Trump
what would you say to him
drinking badass that we have been
waiting for and we thank you you're like
our father our protector and we love you
thank you
folks
folks intervention
is the word that comes to mind this is a
very deep and troubled cult and this is
the sort of you know there was a time
I I know people sometimes get upset when
I do this there was a time where if you
went and in fact you can look at this on
YouTube and I know some people say David
you're you're glamorizing terrible okay
just bear with me if you go on YouTube
and you find examples of right Wingers
from the 60s and 70s who would go to for
example a William F Buckley gnome
Chomsky debate or something like that
and they would get on the mic and they
would ask a question okay they will seem
like the most sane and rational
intellectuals compared to these folks
now in fact if you look at the Trump CNN
Town Hall from last week and you look at
the questions that were asked people who
can barely string a sentence together
and then you look at the folks that
would engage you know with William F
Buckley and others in the 60s 70s 80s of
the United States the right
I am on the left okay so I would come to
different conclusions on policy than
these folks but there were people on the
right in the United States back then
who didn't seem obviously like empty
vessels just following a cult leader
without understanding a word about it
you you go and look at there's some very
interesting videos on YouTube where the
economist Milton Friedman takes
questions from the audience and some of
the questions are from people on the
left and some of the questions are for
people on the right the level of
discourse was
you just can't even compare it to what
has happened to this country
particularly from the anti-intellectual
and pseudo-intellectual left where
college is liberal indoctrination and
books are and all of this stuff
and this is where we end up with cult
members that's where we are at this
point in time here's a guy from the same
rally that was postponed
who without evidence
says to the anchors of real America's
voice
someone from New York has been paying
for my dad's cancer treatment
and I'm sure it's Donald Trump
what do you have any evidence of that no
but I'm just sure but my dad hasn't
received a cancer bill in over five
years and it's been paid 100 by a guy in
New York and that can only be president
Donald J Trump and my dad's cancer-free
yeah that's just made up guys there's no
reason whatsoever to think and by the
way Trump hasn't lived in New York for
years Trump famously while he was
President changed his residency to
Florida like just none of this makes
sense there's no thinking there's no
thinking that's happening here it is
just people praying at the altar of the
cult leader Trump the question of the E
Gene Carroll case did come up in
interviews with some of these supporters
we'll go back to that earlier group we
looked at and they were asked well what
do you think about the Eugene Carroll
thing and here's what they had to say
women for Trump
are you deterred At All by any of the
recent allegations against him or are
you just supporting Trump through and
through because you know that he's an
honest man we think that it's a lie and
yeah
yeah I think he's a good guy they just
don't like it because he's standing up
for America they have demonized him
because he's the one standing up for We
the People he's the only President the
only person who has ever stood up for We
the People he's on our side and that's
why he's been demonized because all the
systems that have been in control are
rigged right
a jury which included trumpists okay
found that Trump was liable for the
sexual assault and defamation of e Gene
Carroll because the jury was angry that
Trump stood up for the American people
you sound I sound like an idiot
repeating it it's it's so stupid it
doesn't make any sense whatsoever here's
one last clip uh folks proudly talking
about the parts of the country they came
from to see this rally tornado watch be
damned
doing great a little wet but I'm drying
off
I'm here during the little the little
rain
yesler had to ring my clothes out now
did people stay did people run what was
it like I never saw anyone leave
isn't that incredible I got a video
actually of just hundreds of people
waiting out here earlier hundreds and
they didn't they didn't move a muscle
they stayed right here waiting to show
their support for proudly ignoring
dangerous weather president Trump now
speaking of support for president Trump
the front row Joe's have always been
some of the most vocal supporters I want
to know today where each of y'all came
from when did you leave how far is that
Journey hey Becky we left the day before
yesterday and just took our time I'm
from Tennessee I came with Mike Bowman
he's from Indiana Mike Bowman Becky
South Dakota six hours
how far did you travel and when did you
leave I came here yesterday it took me
about 11 hours from Ohio okay so as you
can see
a badge of honor the more that you have
struggled and the more that you have
suffered to be in the presence of the
great leader
the more commitment you have
demonstrated this is straight out of a
cult Playbook straight out of a call you
you brag about who has toiled and
suffered the most to be here today
scary stuff many of these people vote
Trump could win in 2024 and so we need
to be on our guard let's go now to Ron
DeSantis when we say the Republican
primary of 2024
. Ron DeSantis isn't actually in that
primary at this point in time he may
announce he may not one of the problems
Ron DeSantis is having is his
personality and Trump posted to truth
social the other day that uh that
DeSantis needs a personality transplant
and he does and here is an example
clearly DeSantis has been advised by
someone I guess you've got to be more
bubbly or whatever
he sounds ridiculous and it so obviously
contrived he's like pretending to be
bubbly now this is DeSantis over the
weekend at the feinstra family picnic in
Iowa this new DeSantis is not
particularly credible but many maybe
some people will like the new bubbly
DeSantis you know sometimes people will
will say to me they'll be
they'll be Governor why aren't other
Republicans doing what you're doing in
Florida and I say they are doing it and
they say where I say they're doing it in
Iowa and in fact this whiny Voice by the
way is really tough I was here in March
and someone kind of took note and
they're like man look at all the stuffs
I was doing Iowa was like the Florida of
the Midwest they said but I just are you
guys following this I want to let you
know after watching all the good stuff
you've done in Iowa it may be that
Florida is the Iowa the southeast so
we'll see there you go wow a new bubbly
DeSantis with a new personality maybe
that's going to appeal to people he then
went to I guess a diner or a restaurant
of some kind with Mike Pence and if you
want if you want a list of people not to
take personality modeling from
I would put my Mike Pence at the top of
that list and here they sit down for
some kind of meal who knows if it's real
or fake or whatever take a look at this
and as you can see Ron DeSantis sitting
very very strongly
all right unclear whether anybody
ordered any food or what the deal with
that was and then we'll just go now to
the closing of Ron desantis's little
speech there at the finstra family
picnic and he tries to energize the
crowd with one of these crescendos but
it only sort of works the crowd seems to
understand this is like a crescendo
finish so they do play along and clap
but it all feels very very forced
it occurred to me that you can have the
best Declaration of Independence in the
world you could have the best
constitution in the world but if you
don't have people that are willing
throughout throughout our history to
stand up put on that uniform risk their
lives and in many instances give that
last full measure of devotion then it
isn't going to amount to very much and
so we are not called upon to make
sacrifices of that magnitude but we're
also called upon to do battle in the
political Arena so what I say to you as
Republicans put on the full armor of God
take your stand stand firm for truth we
must fight the good fight we must finish
the race and we must keep the faith I
can tell you this I am proud of what
we've done in Florida inspiring an
electric speech as you can see I'm
thankful we're Governor Reynolds and the
team have done in Iowa but I've only
begun to fight thank you all God bless
you it's so great to be in Iowa
thank you so much
thank you God bless you all
it all feels so empty
it feels vapid it feels
ridiculous
and yet it's like a pantomime of a real
campaign with a real candidate now he
may declare and it may become a real
campaign and I guess to some degree that
will make him a real candidate the
numbers look very bad for DeSantis I
want someone to run against Trump I want
someone to credibly do it the numbers
just don't seem to be falling into
Santa's favor so we'll see what decision
he ultimately makes and he has to make
that decision soon I think within the
next four to six weeks or that's going
to do it Mike pillow also known as Mike
Lindell the CEO and founder of my pillow
was in Des Moines Iowa for Donald
Trump's canceled rally this was the
rally that due to depending on who or
what you believe either because of a
tornado watch or because of low
attendance depending on who you ask
there's conflicting views was canceled
my pillow Mike Lindell was there and he
made an incredible statement
he says he has blown I'm calling it
blown he says spent he has blown 40
million dollars on all of this election
nonsense now the last time I interviewed
pillow or prillo as some call him he he
told me he was at 35 million spent as of
that point in time we're doing a class
action lawsuit against
clearly the machine lawsuits have upped
that to 40 million here he is explaining
it what we're doing with
prison we're offering stock to the
public I want every person out there to
have a little piece of the pie our boys
for this country I went with the money
that I use to save this country that
I've been outspending I've spent over 40
million dollars unbelievable hang on a
second he's spent over 40 million
dollars on nothing on on literally
nothing
nah I need help you know we need help
but we need help making a voice bigger
yeah and we need help uh the money that
we've and you'll see this when this
happens I can't tell the details the
lawyer said I will only let you tell
this much you know yes they see yeah
okay so pillow I mean listen I it's
increasingly a sad story I believe
pillow is a True Believer he does seem
to believe this stuff and according to
various reports he's wrecked his family
life with this election nonsense and he
spent 40 million bucks I think he has
like two or three hundred million so
he's still going to be fine but that's a
lot of money to waste he then during the
same interview if you can call it that
says he put bed bath and be excuse me
bed bath it's so ridiculous I'm choking
on my own words he says that he's
responsible for Bed Bath and Beyond's
bankruptcy because they stopped carrying
his pillows or something you know they
were afraid in fear and and they uh I
said no the real people are gonna are
gonna not gonna shop there if you do
this to me yeah and that's what happened
that's exactly what happened but you you
know I feel bad that all those jobs are
lost these ones that are going bankrupt
and stuff um we um
If Only They had my pillow pillows
available uh they would have been saved
that is uh that is a cautionary tale
okay and then lastly this is now totally
Beyond parody he pillow claims he has
new election crime evidence he's no
longer calling it election fraud he's
now calling it election crime and he
says that in two weeks it's going to be
released talk real quickly about what
you talked about the crime and when can
when can we expect that okay this is
real important that Allah you can go to
electioncrimebureau.com right the
electric crime Bureau I formed about uh
oh about a month and a half ago now and
uh within two weeks that's why I say
we're getting together now okay so in
two weeks they're gonna be publishing
that information you would think that by
now his family would have intervened
except it seems as though the
relationship with his family is wrecked
so they may have completely lost control
of pillow a sad and cautionary tale okay
the conspiracies can drive you closer to
bankruptcy it's not just benign when you
believe in this stuff you could get
grifted into donating to someone like
pillow or Trump or you could end up uh
you know skating off with the for 40 40
million dollars and uh of being in in
the situation pillow now finds himself I
don't expect any big election crime
Bombshells in two weeks but I I've been
wrong before just not about this topic
and I could be wrong again
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
well in the United States it was
Mother's day yesterday and the failed
former and wannabe future president
Donald Trump issued a Mother's Day
greeting I guess with peace love and
attacks on women married to marxists or
something like that then degenerating
into an even more unhinged attack on
Caitlyn Collins and other people let's
take a very quick look at it this was
all on Trump's platform truth social
Trump not resp reactivating in any
serious way on Twitter but regularly
posting to truth starting with quote
happy Mother's Day to all in particular
the mothers Wives and Lovers of the
radical left fascists marxists and
Communists who are doing everything
within their power to destroy and
obliterate our once great Capital C
country please make these complete
capital L lunatics and capital M Maniacs
capital K Kinder capital G gentler
capital S softer and most importantly
yes capital S smarter so that we can
quickly make America great again
this is a really really sick Mother's
Day message
and a bizarre one he then turned his ire
from the lovers lovers of marxists to
Ron DeSantis posting quote Rob Des
sanctimonious and his poll numbers are
dropping like a rock
I would almost be inclined to say these
are record Falls the question is Rob
just young inexperienced or naive or
more troubling is he a fool who has no
idea what he is doing we already have
one of those in office we don't need
another one Maga so an attack on Rob Des
sanctimonious then going after Caitlyn
Collins who was the host of the Trump
CNN Town Hall that went so horribly
wrong last week posting quote it's
really amazing to watch the head of CNN
get absolutely lambasted for asking me
to do a so-called Town Hall in all
fairness nobody had any problems with
what he wanted to do until after the
show started that's a lie many people
had a problem with it when they quickly
realized that Ms Collins was not exactly
Barbara Walters or even close that's
when the trouble from the radical left
started neurotic little AOC with the bad
looking boyfriend went crazy he owns CNN
he's in their head they screamed CNN
take the great ratings you know I I have
to say one this is this is whacked
completely whacked out of his gourd but
one thing that does seem to be true
is that the Trump CNN Town Hall reminded
others like Fox News maybe there's a few
ratings points to be had with very
little effort in doing Trump stuff and
so until the Iowa rally was canceled
over the weekend Trump's Iowa rally was
canceled Fox News planned to air it
even though for a while now they have
not aired Trump's rallies which is
interesting and clearly a reaction to
what they saw work relatively well for
CNN now one last note on this to be
thorough
the actual live ratings for the Trump
CNN Town Hall weren't that good they
were like in the 3 million range
the issue is it generated so much
discussion and the clips were shared and
it was discussed for days that CNN got a
lot of mileage out of it but the the
live event itself didn't actually do
that well from a ratings perspective
okay and then lastly as part of this
deranged rant from Trump on Truth quote
unless the Republicans get everything
they are asking for in terms of cost
cutting in particular all of the
trillions of dollars of inflation
causing waste that has stupidly been
approved over the last two years much of
it for the green New Deal con job they
will have no choice but to let the Biden
Administration default on U.S debt
better now than later especially with 32
trillion dollars of debt out there when
I was President the Dems would
cavalierly say they don't care about
default so so many lies here so many
lies first of all the deficit has
actually grown I'm sorry the debt has
grown more slowly under Biden than under
Trump so the idea of Biden is this out
of control spending guy that's a lie
secondly the green new deal is not law
and continuing to talk about all of the
spending on Green New Deal the green new
deal is not law the inflation reduction
act does contain certain things like
we're going to build electric vehicle
Chargers and things like that but there
is no green New Deal in the law right
now and lastly the idea of trump saying
let the U.S default on its debt it's
ridiculous it's not going to happen and
they love to pretend like it actually
might but I don't think even Trump
understands what would happen if that
were the case so A beautiful Mother's
Day on Troth Central for failed former
president Donald Trump
white supremacists marched in Washington
D.C wearing masks by the way I guess
they're not that confident in the world
knowing who they are and what they
believe there's a Newsweek report
um hundreds of white supremacists march
on Capital with shields and battle drums
we'll look at a video in a moment video
posted to social media showed hundreds
of members of the white supremacist
group Patriot front marched to the
United States capital carrying Shields
and battle drums on Saturday by the way
I hear sometimes supremacists pronounced
supremacist
like I think Lindsey Graham says it that
way and some others I don't know where
they're getting supremaced
supremacist is the word at least 150
members of the far-right group wearing
masks to conceal their identity were
seen marching along the National Mall
and in downtown DC videos posted to
Twitter showed them carrying American
flags and holding signs that red reclaim
America the March comes as experts warn
about the rise of white supremacist
groups and sentiment in the U.S
according to a study from the
Anti-Defamation League from March a 38
increase in white supremacist activity
was seen from 2021 to 2022 with more
than 67 incidents reported throughout
the year in the videos police officers
are seen escorting Patriot front members
to separate them from counter protesters
so we have a video here I will describe
it for the people that are only
listening today you do indeed see a
police sort of escort I think is on
bikes around the Patriot front guys they
all seem to be wearing I guess the
uniform they've chosen is tight khaki
pants although I don't know that they're
supposed to be tight some of them may
just have pants that are too small tight
khaki pants and then blue shirts masks
and hats they are Marching they are
carrying Shields
let's listen
right
thank you
now as we continue to watch this and you
see the police escort closing around
them
what is the deal with the shields
I don't know
wow
and off they go
why do they hide their identities
clearly they realize there might be real
world consequences to being identified
as white supremacists I don't know
all right so if you look online there's
a bunch of magas convinced that this is
a false flag event now what they mean by
that I don't really know I guess what
they're saying is it's a false flag in
that these aren't really white
supremacists
this is actually
antifa or I don't know BLM or Hunter
Biden's extended family I don't know
it's people pretending to be white
supremacists
and white supremacists don't really
exist maybe I I don't really know but
you would then ask yourself if it's a
false flag they should have no problem
denouncing what they stand for even if
they're pretending to stand for that but
they don't do that either
it's all very weird but white
supremacists marching in DC with uh
tight pants boots masks Flags some of
the flags upside down and a uh extremely
extremely solid police escort I must say
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P here's a caller making
a point about those who love to say I've
done my research take a listen to this
hi David I think we really need to push
back against people who say they do
their own research or just this idea
that research is something you can do
research is a term used to describe what
phds do it's used to describe
Grant funded activities costing millions
of dollars with tens of thousands of
people involved this idea that people
are doing research is absurd okay what
they're actually doing is consuming
information are they critical of that
information are they consuming the right
kinds of information these are the
things we need to be discussing but when
it comes to discussions about should you
do your own research or whatever it's
absurd because they're using this term
research inappropriately okay I get the
idea so what we're talking about here
this is interesting they're talking
about colloquial versus formal language
and I'll give you another example many
people will often say in casual
conversation or either like a political
analyst will say I have a theory or
people will write to me and say David I
have a theory the term Theory
in science means it's a scientific
theory meaning well substantiated
explanation of some aspect of the world
we have vast evidence we have
observations we have experimentation
logical reasoning it's a comprehensive
framework that the science Community has
said this is the best explanation we
have for some phenomena and it is
evidence-based Etc it's been tested it's
often been peer reviewed Etc it's been
scrutinized in casual conversation when
we say I have a theory we know that what
you mean is you have a hypothesis and
yeah sure to some degree would it be
more accurate for people to say I have a
hypothesis about what's going to happen
in 2024 sure it's more accurate but
sometimes we use the same words
differently when it's colloquial versus
when it's formal when we talk about
research it's true when someone says
when some anti-vax person says I did my
research or when I say it or whatever
the case may be we're talking about
someone who is gathering information
it's it's an it's an information
gathering process with which you then
are ideally coming to some conclusion
about phenomena in everyday life do
vaccines cause autism well I've
researched it okay what you mean is you
gathered information that others have
done other research other people have
done true actual research would be we
are comprehensively and systematically
um uh using established methodologies to
generate new knowledge and then they are
being peer reviewed and okay I get it
research is a rigorous methodology that
most of us are not doing when we say
we're doing our research however I would
focus more on the people who say I've
done my research
often what they mean is they read a
foxnews.com article we would do better I
believe instead of saying random people
don't do research you're not working in
an academic research setting or a
medical research setting instead of
focusing on that I would focus on giving
people a better structure
for getting information about topics
they're trying to learn about so they
don't end up on conspiracy websites I
think we would get more from that but
obviously the voicemail is accurate in
that the term research means something
that is very different than you know
sitting at home and looking at a daily
wire article I agree with that 100 we
have a great bonus show for you today we
will talk about George Santos agreeing
to settle a lawsuit in Brazil this is
separate from the criminal charges we
will talk about the North Carolina
governor vetoing a 12-week abortion ban
and we will talk about split juries and
the impact and Legacy that this has left
in prisons all over the country all of
those stories and more are on today's
bonus show which you can sign up for and
get instant access to at joinpakman.com
see everybody tomorrow
foreign